this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant
a problem-solving website that teaches
you to think like an engineer
at the height of the cold war with
nuclear anxiety at a fever pitch
the united states launched their first
spy satellites the corona
tasked with photographing deep inside
the soviet union
us intelligence was focused on searching
for signs of nuclear weapon development
and testing
but found a lot more than they bargained
for these early satellites were launched
with rolls of film with no way of
transmitting the data contained within
them
to earth through electronic means and
thus the film had to be recovered and
developed
here on earth once the film was filled
the satellite would eject a re-entry
vehicle
containing the precious undeveloped
photos back to earth where they could be
caught by a passing plane as they
drifted down
on one such mission a strange object
began to emerge
from the caspian sea as the film
developed a gigantic aircraft
nearly 100 meters long with short stubby
wings
much too short to fly like a
conventional aircraft
us intelligence had never seen anything
like it
as they received more pictures it was
clear the craft was moving at the same
speed as a traditional aircraft while
outsizing
even the largest of modern day american
military planes like the lockheed c5m
it was even emblazoned with the flag of
the soviet navy not the soviet air force
this discovery set alarm bells off
within u.s
intelligence had the soviets developed a
breakthrough in propulsion
which could give them the upper hand in
naval combat
confused on what they were seeing the us
dubbed the machine the caspian sea
monster
but the soviets weren't developing a
gigantic hydrofoil or seaplane
this giant aircraft secretly being
developed was actually an ecranoplan
a gigantic vessel capable of skimming
across the ocean's surface at high
speeds
in 1962 the central hydrofoil design
bureau
assigned chief designer rastaslav
alexiev to begin working on a prototype
plane
alexeyev had cut his teeth developing
hydrofoil planes like the raquetta
these craft can easily be defined as a
boat they used a hydrofoil
essentially a wing designed to act in
water to lift the boat's hull
out of the water as against speed
allowing it to reduce drag and increase
top speeds but the soviets wanted to
take this a step further
the chronoplan would make use of
something called ground effect
to fly at a very low altitude above the
ocean's surface
ground effect occurs when a fixed wing
aircraft flies at an altitude
less than the length of its wingspan as
large masses of air come into contact
with the aircraft the profile of the
wing deflects the air
downwards compressing the air between
the wing and the ground
this trapped air can cause an area of
higher than normal pressure
under the wing resulting in a boost to
lift
this happens with all aircraft during
takeoff and landing
and is something all pilots have to
learn to deal with for example
some planes can get off the ground when
overloaded but won't be able to climb
past the altitude where ground effect is
in play ekranoplans are designed in such
a way to maximize
this effect and never leave the ground
effect zone
just as our plane can get off the ground
when overloaded the ukranoplan can be
heavier without the need for extra power
an aircraft with this ability could be a
powerful tool in open sea combat
it would fly under enemy radar for much
longer due to the radar shadow
under the earth's curvature it would be
capable of transporting tons of
equipment and personnel
quickly while avoiding enemy mines and
torpedoes
or it could be fitted with weapons of
its own to quickly attack enemy ships
before
escaping imagine if a vehicle like this
was available for the d-day landings the
largest amphibious assault in history
the allies would have been able to
transport tons of equipment and troops
across the channel in a 15-minute trip
the appeal of the technology was
enormous and the first prototype named
the km
was built and secretly transported to
the caspian sea to begin testing
this enormous vehicle instantly became
the largest aircraft
ever built with a wingspan of 37.6
meters and a length of 92 meters
it weighed a massive 240 tonnes but it
could take off with almost double that
powered by eight dobrynin vd7 turbo jets
mounted at the front and two on the tail
which provided a total of 1
275 kilonewtons of thrust about 30
percent more than a boeing 747
the first test flight of the km took
place on the 16th of october
1966 with chief designer alexiev on
board
at the time it was forbidden for soviet
aircraft designers to be on board test
vehicles like this
in case they were involved in an
accident but test pilot vladimir
loganoff
lobbied for alexiev to be on board to
allow him to experience and refine his
designs
the first tests were successful showing
the km could fly with optimum fuel
efficiency
at 430 kilometers per hour and with a
maximum operational speed of 500
kilometers per hour
during some high-speed tests it's
claimed that it achieved a speed of 650
kilometers per hour
the km was a valuable proof of concept
and laid the groundwork for all
future ecranoplants alexiev took the
lessons learned and began to develop
a new transport version designed
specifically for the transport of
military equipment and troops
called the orleonock this was a much
smaller variant
58 meters long with a 31.5 meter
wingspan
and a maximum takeoff weight of 140
metric tons
its engine layout was fascinating with a
massive mk12
turboprop engine mounted on the tail as
far away from the salt water as possible
these massive six meter diameter counter
rotating turbo propellers
developed 11 000 kilowatts of power
making it the most powerful turboprop
engine to
ever enter service it also featured two
nose-mounted turbofan engines with air
intakes on top of the nose to minimize
water intake
the exhaust of these engines were
pointed under the wings to enhance the
ground effect phenomenon
by bolstering the air cushion with the
high pressure output of the jet engine
these engines were only needed on
takeoff before the plane could gain the
speed needed to develop enough lift
through the wing and ground effect once
this was achieved they were shut down to
decrease
fuel consumption the orleanuk featured a
nose-mounted cargo door
and wheels to allow the plane to drive
onto land and unload
this was a fully functional ecranoplan
and actually entered and remained in
service until 1993
although only four were ever built
details from here vary and i found it
difficult to find an authoritative
source of information on what happened
to alexiev
after the development of the orlando
knock was complete some say he crashed
in the km
others in the orleans and others say he
crashed in a volga too
a small passenger transport akranoplan
but they all seem to point towards
alexia have been fired as chief designer
as a result and dying a short time later
whether that was from injuries from the
crash or natural causes
i have no idea with alexiev out of the
picture
and the soviet union on the brink of
collapse development of akronoplans in
the soviet union
slowly began to fizzle out they managed
to develop a slightly smaller version of
the km
designed to launch anti-ship missiles
while out at sea
in 1987 the first version of this
vehicle was built and named the lun
this vehicle weighed 286 tons had a
length of 74 meters
and a wingspan of 44 meters the tail
mounted engines were removed completely
it was instead powered by eight nk 87
turbofans mounted on the front of the
craft
each producing 127 kilonewtons of thrust
valon entered the soviet navy in 1987
however with the collapse of the soviet
union in 1991
only one model was ever completed and it
remains in its dry dock
on the shores of the caspian sea to this
day
the idea of a wing and ground effect
plane has its merits
but it has simply never found its niche
in any military
the germans made a smaller acronym plan
in the 70s called the x-114
but it never made it into service the
chinese also experimented with an
acronym plan called the xtw4
which was built in 1999 and went through
multiple tests a year later
the vehicle was once spotted in a
chinese shipping port on google maps
but has since vanished while in 2002
boeing presented their plans to build
the largest ecranoplan
ever dubbed the pelican they claimed the
craft would be longer than a football
field
and capable of hauling 17 m1 abram tanks
across an
ocean but the u.s congress rejected the
plans in 2005
there just wasn't a need for such a
plane wing in ground effect planes
may yet find their niche but for now
safety and reliability concerns
are its primary roadblock flying at such
a low altitude
provides very little time for corrective
maneuvers and poor weather with high
waves or wind
prevents any ekranoplan from operating
some have sought to develop
smaller passenger versions like the a050
which the russian embassy of south
africa your definitive russian news
source
claimed it would be ready for service in
the next three years
vehicles like this could find a valuable
niche in archipelago regions like
southeast asia where increasing wealth
and populations
combined with relatively short distances
between islands
could provide a market for these
temperamental craft
however traditional planes will always
remain a much more efficient and
reliable form of transport
over long distances as flying in the
lower density air of the upper
atmosphere
drastically decreases drag so these
passenger versions would have to operate
extremely short haul distances where
airliners waste time during climbing and
ascent
this technology is perfectly viable for
the right application
and we may yet see someone solve the
problem and build a successful business
from it
that could be you but you will first
have to learn how to solve problems
a good place to start is through
brilliant daily challenges
each day brilliant presents you with
interesting scientific and mathematical
problems to test your brain
each daily challenge provides you with
the context and framework that you need
to tackle it
so that you can learn the concepts by
applying them if you like the problem
and want to learn more
there's a course that explores the same
concept in greater detail
if you are confused and need more
guidance there's a community of
thousands of learners discussing the
problems and writing solutions
daily challenges are thought-provoking
challenges that will lead you from
curiosity
to mastery one day at a time if i have
inspired you and you want to educate
yourself
then go to brilliant.org forward slash
real engineering and sign up for free
and the first 500 people that go to that
link will get 20
off the annual premium subscription so
you can get full access to
all their courses as well as their
entire daily challenges archive
as always thanks for watching and thank
you to all my patreon supporters
if you'd like to see more from me the
links to my instagram twitter
subreddit and discord server are below